[Applause]
[Music]
Olivia and chilli are the 50 cent and
kanye west's of latin america now it is
true they share a border but other than
laughter they couldn't be more different
olivia is one of the poorest countries
on the whole continents while Chile is
among the wealthiest Bolivia is a
paragon of the so called indigenous
socialism while Chile is known as the
mordoor of neoliberalism and as if this
was not enough the two countries are
involved in seemingly never-ending
territorial disputes with each other
nonetheless now there is one thing that
these two countries have in common
yes if you are we are talking about
white gold damn damn
no no no no that type of white gold I'm
talking here about lithium lithium is
use for the manufacturing of battery
that's power your cell phone your laptop
and those electric cars Berg eventually
might flood our roads and highways the
cotton new oil
it's the latest metal on the periodic
table its value has gone up tenfold in
the last two decades alone and its
demand won't stop growing
between 60 and 80% of the world's known
reserves are in an area called the
lithium triangle this is an area that
covers parts of Argentina Bolivia and
Chile in these countries lithium is
abundant and easy to extract in other
words this part of the planet might soon
become a new Saudi Arabia the form that
it's found in is found in like these
dried-up salt lakes solarz so or brines
which is very different than getting
lithium out of hard rock it's much
cheaper much more effective among those
three countries Bolivia is the luckiest
one the so called salar de uyuni holds
two or three times more lithium reserves
than the mines in argentina or in chile
now on the other hand chile already has
a world-class mining industry however
despite these reserves bolivia is
exporting less lithium than the other
two countries and Chile might actually
soon be out of this new white gold rush
in fact Argentina is the nation that is
getting the most attention from
international investors so today's
question has to be what's going on in
Bolivia why is no one exploiting their
lithium resources and why is Chile
following suit today we're going to
answer all of those questions but before
we do let's take a look at the history a
new potosi now if you've been subscribed
to visual politic for a while you
already know that having natural
resources doesn't mean that you are rich
Bolivia is an excellent example of this
[Music]
the country has all the natural wealth
you can imagine lithium silver natural
gas nevertheless it is still one of the
poorest countries in all of South
America the silver mines of potosi were
the site of war for the Spanish crown
during the 16th and 17th centuries in
fact Spaniards still say this is worth a
potosi meaning that something is too
expensive but the native Bolivians
didn't reap the benefits of that silver
wealth and millions died under the
extreme working conditions in the mines
this is why it's pretty understandable
that the government of Evo Morales is so
reluctant to in our foreign companies to
get into the country and extract the
lithium
besides let's be honest the real
business here is not the raw materials
but in the industry that comes
afterwards for a better understanding of
this while we make this video a metric
tonne of lithium costs around $9,000 on
the international market but if we take
that raw lithium and we turn it into
batteries for mobile phones we can turn
that lithium into a value of somewhere
between 1.5 and 5 million dollars of
course this is just a rough estimated
value and there are a lot of things that
should be considered here but it can
help to look at a comparison indeed it
can help explain news like this a
Brazilian state Abel Morales keynote at
Evo Morales opened in 2013 the first
plant of lithium carbonate and in
February 2014 the first manufacturing
facility for lithium-ion batteries but
that is not all in Bolivia lithium is
nationalized this means that if you are
a private mining company and you want to
work on Bolivian soil
you must partner with the government and
start a new company which will be owned
partly by the government this new
company can get paid for their service
and building the mines setting up the
machinery and extracting the lithium
Marta the lithium they extract well that
belongs to the government they have no
rights to sell
[Music]
so now you might be wondering why does
Olivia need foreign companies to exploit
their own wealth can't they simply do it
themselves well the short answer is no
modern-day mining it has nothing to do
with the image you probably have in your
mind of it going with a hard hat and a
pickaxe today mining requires high-end
machinery and world-class engineers as
you can imagine these things are scarce
in the country as poor as the Libya if
you wanted to create a competitive
mining industry in that country without
outside help you would need decades this
is why it is so important to utilize
companies who have the technology the
tools and the staff to do the job and
this is why even Morales himself
unfriendly to multinationals have said
that it's time to get out there and find
investors in the little containers as
soon as we have a big lithium industry
Olivia will set the lithium price for
the whole world down general athelas I
want to say to you
governments and private companies now
you can join us
[Music]
so all right so what exactly is the
problem here well as I said before
Bolivian lithium is owned by the state
this means that companies that might
invest in the country can only get a
profit by partnering with the government
and from that profit they must pay a
special mining tax that goes up to 37.5%
which is by far the largest in the
region and if all of this wasn't enough
well according to the World Bank Bolivia
ranks among the 50 countries where it is
hardest to do business they rank at
about the same level as Sierra Leone
so now let's say that you're someone who
wants to invest in lithium things can't
be investing in Bolivia or maybe you
might prefer one of those other
countries you know maybe this explains
why at the moment Bolivia while it is
the country with the biggest lithium
resources it is also the country that is
exploiting them the least if you pay
attention to the chart here you will see
that today the leader of the lithium
race is Australia
[Music]
this is surprising because the resources
of this country are four times smaller
than those of Bolivia South Australian
salaries are six times higher than
Bolivian ones so as you can see this is
not a matter of low paid jobs or natural
wealth but simply good and bad economic
policies but hold on just a minute
because this is not the only problem so
forget that Evo Morales dream is for
Bolivia to become a manufacturing leader
in the lithium battery industry but how
exactly is he going to achieve this
without foreign companies setting up
inside the country
[Music]
all right so yeah the government can set
up its own factory and that's all great
and everything but technology patterns
and the skills needed they're held by
companies like Panasonic Samsung or
Tesla without these Olivia would need
decades of research in order to be
competitive on the international market
all right so a while ago we mentioned
Chile now let's go and have a look at
what's happening over there they follows
in the steps of Bolivia for years Chile
has been known as something of a
free-market Disneyland well precisely
their mining industry was one of the
freest in the entire world we're talking
about the country whether your colony
relies heavily on copper mining this is
why in the year 1981 Pinochet
dictatorship passed the so-called
mining law this allowed private
businesses to own 100% of a mind as you
can imagine this law kick-started
foreign investment in the country
suddenly lots of companies like the
Australian bhp Billington or the Swiss
Xstrata came to Chile and yeah listen I
know you're thinking all these
multinational companies well they looted
the country and left it in poverty right
right well actually that's totally wrong
of course these Canadian Swiss and
Australian companies came to extract the
copper
but they also help to finance lots of
brand-new companies which employ Chilean
workers and we're headquartered in
Santiago companies like manera as can be
de or Antofagasta mining in fact thanks
to this wave of investors Chile now has
a world-class mining industry actually
many of the engineers that are now
needed in Bolivia bathe live in the best
neighborhood to Santiago and this means
that Chile has been in a great position
to lead this white Gold Rush nonetheless
in 2016 Chilean President Michelle
Bachelet declared that Elysium was a
different animal firm the strategic
condition of lithium which is property
of all Chilean people and will keep its
state as non-concessional material in
other words the government of Chile is
following suit with Bolivia bar so they
do have an important difference in this
case the country already has the
technology and the staff to exploit its
mineral wealth in an efficient way of
course many of these companies who were
willing to invest in the country have
lost all interest but Chile has its own
companies so it's not so big a deal
besides until 2014 the other countries
of this lithium triangle Argentina and
Bolivia well way worse places for
investment so in this case is sort of
like in the land of the blind the
one-eyed person is king well they until
now Argentina has been the big surprise
here while Chile and Bolivia have
nationalized the lithium and have tried
badly to scare away foreign companies
Argentina with Mauricio Macri as its
president is doing something rather
different and they're now getting all
the attention from international
investors
[Music]
[Applause]
but we're actually going to talk about
that in upcoming weeks in a sort of
second part of this video so if you
don't want to miss that please do be
sure to subscribe to this channel in the
meantime we've got a question for you do
you think that Bolivia and Chile can
reap the benefits of their lithium with
these kinds of policies or maybe
Argentina will somehow overshadow them
you can leave me an answer in the
comment section below and just before we
go today I've got a really important
question and sort of a request from you
you might have notice that we'd rather
like using rock music in our videos and
we'd love to hear from anyone who has a
band and thinks that their music could
be a good fit for us well of course
gives you full credit in the video if we
do use your music if you're interested
in doing that please drop us an email
you can do that that info app visual
politics on net also please don't forget
to visit our friends at being Rican to
the media podcasts they provided the
vocals in those episodes that are not
mine and if you liked this video give it
a thumbs up and otherwise see you next
time
[Music]